all right so this was a huge story last
night when I broke Greg and you know
tapes Trump Cohen all over Twitter and
then when I listened to it I kind of was
left with a feeling of like is that it
it always it's that way with every story
like this there's this huge explosion
and then everybody is deflated it's they
say it's a smoking gun it's like a soggy
cigarette but there's some there's some
things about this that I got first as an
editor okay she took money for this what
right does she have to say where and if
the story runs you got paid doesn't
matter I've paid for stories and I've
killed stories that's not against the
law so that's baloney also Cohen's
lawyer is Lanny Davis he worked for
Hillary he's a housecoat entman I mean
this is revenge so that's that in itself
is collusion also it's a sad day in
America when you can no longer trust
hush money it is called hush money you
got a you got a slimy lawyer you've got
women that are that had sex and where it
was paid for it and consensually this is
okay I just find it so ridiculous that
people are screaming about the fact that
a billionaire real estate developer in
Manhattan who has been thrice-married
known as a womanizer might have paid a
woman to not talk about an affair
I mean how you'd find more meat at a
vegan hot dog eating contest
this is the good old days when hush
money really counts exactly back in the
face of LA Confidential come on you
can't trust it hush money we were saying
in the break about this is the 90s again
you have Lanny Davis Keith on defending
the Clintons and now out there with Rudy
Giuliani who's also you know these two
you know legal Titans that are just
playing this out a big game of chicken
on cable television
it was curious to me why Cohen decided
to go with Lanny Davis or while and it's
more clear to me now why Lanny Davis
decided to take the case it is also
something to be said that Lanny Davis is
actually willing to go on TV and defend
his client and so
Rudy Giuliani had been out there
basically kind of by himself except for
avenatti was out there but on a
different case whatever I'm not sure
about the strategy of releasing tapes
because what's the long-term goal was it
the new cycle that you want to achieve I
don't think that if the Southern
District of New York is looking into
Michael Cohen's activities that this is
not going to get the Southern District
of New York off their back so what is
the goal is the goal to try to embarrass
the president to get a new cycle to say
that there are other tapes means that
they better be better tapes than that
one right because if you put out another
tape that's like well we wait that
there's it's worse than a soggy
cigarette yes then a damn sparkler yes
that you can't use again there will be
that but here's the other thing though
that this is the second time that the
administration has put out information
that turns out to be false later on and
so reporters for example that went out
and said I think was February or
November of last year we hear there's
this payment that was made to this Karen
mcdu nope never heard of it nope nope
nope nope and then turns out actually
it's true does that go back to that
everybody lies about sex mantra in the
nineties but now the shoes on the other
foot no I haven't done either I don't
know the golden no the golden rule is
you deny deny deny until it happens and
you know okay you got me what do you
think about this and what do you think
about the strategy that Dana brought up
well I bring this up now while I leaked
the tape is it to show you have a little
independence and to make the president a
little nervous but also brush off the
New York prosecutors well according to
Lanny Rudy Giuliani was you know
demeaning his client and bad-mouthing
him and so they wanted to push back and
in fact it was interesting to me that
Davis said Michael Kohn was no longer
seeking any pardon so the question then
becomes oh so maybe Michael Cohen is now
cooperating with prosecutors looking
into President Trump but what strikes me
about this is you guys are so dismissive
the wet cigarette butt I mean on so many
levels I mean well first I guess it
plays into what Trump was saying
yesterday to the bets about don't
believe anything you're here don't
believe anything you read just just
listen to me I mean talk about an
autocrat oh yeah this is the way it is
now the press have
body else nobody quieting the press
let's throw the critics out let's take
away their clearance for no reason all
okay but here we have a situation where
as Dana said that were denials he said
on I never I don't know anything about
just like in the other in the stormy
Daniels case so Jesse I mean you guys
think
the Trump supporters just say I don't
just and if you bother them before Jim
on they're not it's not gonna bother the
man how many times have you three have
to be proven to be alive it's it's but
it's the same life exact so having sex
having sex exactly it's interesting
because the media suddenly cares about
two things they care about infidelity
and they care about deceit when it was
Bill Clinton you couldn't talk about the
infidelity it was unrelated it was
unimportant please you had people from
the National Organization for Women
standing behind him he was doing that it
was absurd and you couldn't talk about
deceit when Hillary Clinton was lying
outright saying oh I don't know what the
C stands for when she had signed
documents that said in fact yes she did
know that the system for confidential so
I think the media suddenly being alert
is is really refreshing I think Lanny
Davis was a good choice though because
he's very media savvy I'm talking before
I've done a lot of TV with him I think
this is an issue that he knew there may
not be something illegal going on here
there may not be something like that but
we want to sway the public opinion on
Donald Trump we want to try to get those
people who care about honesty and
integrity and who voted for him yes
they've also humiliated him a little
humiliating they want someone who's
going to be able to get on television
and do that but actually when he's good
at that I'm sorry to jump in Jesse I'm
just curious like winkin when was the
last time you had two dynamic lawyers
battling it out in the press theory of
evolution it's been a really long time
you wasn't you just see this on in sit
on yep dramas right on television or in
the movies this is actually plane at
Albany is probably really jealous
this is like Trump's mentor Roy Cohn you
know that's how Cohan used to do
business he'd get in and he'd fight in
the press
well again the key to me is that you get
even Judge Napolitano unlike my
colleagues here saying hmm I think that
there's some fraud here where's the
fraud
well the fraud would be these trying to
set up as the Wall Street Journal
reported this afternoon a shell company
okay to manage the payment because the
payment was made from American media
nationally because the show to have full
ownership of the secrets yes in case
anything happened to the exactly so how
is that a fraud
well because David Berst that they
weren't selling shells at all but
secondly I think the key point here is
that you have the National Enquirer
buying a story in the immediate run-up
to the election so clearly this is about
avoiding this embarrassing story
breaking right before the audience this
is a campaign finance violation
punishable by a fifteen thousand dollar
fine two points on this I love the fact
that Cohen who was just months ago an
untrustworthy slime ball is now the
history of the resistor in bed with him
that's unsavory but to your point I
think it's important what is the media's
endgame I actually I think that CNN I
don't blame them for doing this story
because it's it's interesting that
number but where is this where where do
you want this to go impeachment I'm I'm
not so worried about with I don't care
what the media I don't think the media
actually has an agenda on how they want
it to go they just want the story to
keep going I want to know what is laning
Davis's and game what's the Strad
looking here but the thing is let's say
this I mean I think that there are
people in the media who want Trump out
the problem is they haven't thought
about what's the next day like with 66
million people who think you've just
gotten rid of an incredibly president
today that said that I think was like 65
percent of Democrats do not want to push
for impeachment it's almost like they
finally started to get the memo that for
well to your point if it looks like you
take away the presidency from somebody
for a campaign finance violations for
50,000
I'm not saying that's going to happen
but if that's the perception then you
won't recover reelection oh can I just
say they're also thinking about
reelection and they're saying if we
don't have something substantive here to
impeach him on you have to think about
his potential for re-election and
they're hoping that character issues
come into play when in fact it's so
ridiculous because had you said before
no one voted for Donald Trump saying
this is a wholesome guy it's a great guy
without standing character no they saw a
good businessman they wanted their taxes
lowers they hated Obamacare they wanted
more jobs and guess what all those
things that were important to them he's
delivering delivering on that means the
economy is roaring right what happens in
a midterm when the economy is roaring
the election turns into a values
election and that's what the Democrats
are well I just think the evangelicals
I'm here just wondering how at what
point did the evangelicals say you know
this is total corruption in terms of our
morals funny thing about what Giuliani
said last night on lower income was oh
man I've got lots of experience I've
listened to 4,000 hours of mob tapes I'm
like wait a second I thought you were on
Trump side now you're making out he was
responding to Atlanta so because he said
lay people like that talking cash or
mobsters yeah and guess what that's what
it sounded was going on he said no cash
all right actually mind if there's a
little mob in Trump because you just got
the EU to agree to some like major some
major trade deal go back to the 70s and
Nixon and E Howard hunt I think you'd
enjoy that I was I was at baseball cards
no you can go back